1291 and the Mamluks have conquered acha
defense of the Holy Land over the past
couple of centuries had fallen to the
militant holy orders
the most famous of them all being the
order of the temple the Knights Templar
after the fall of akka the Templars fled
to Cyprus and from there many of them
returned to Europe over the next year
the order desperately sought the backing
of the Pope and of the European monarchs
to support them in another crusade to
retake the Holy Land this help wasn't
forthcoming and so the Knights Templar
had a bit of an identity crisis it was
an order which existed to protect
pilgrims moving to from and within the
Holy Lands and without a Holy Land what
were they supposed to do the Knights
Templar also operated in Europe via a
series of temples and banks which
together made the order extremely
extremely wealthy also the money they
lent gave them considerable leverage
over the people in their debt Philippe
the fourth of France was one such debtor
and he was worried about the Templars
turning their attention to European
affairs the Templars also had the
backing of the Pope on a fast the 8th
from Philippe had been feuding with for
a while now
fortunately Philippe and Boniface would
work out their differences by which I
mean Philippe would have the Pope
kidnapped and he would soon after his
release died in 1305 a new pope clement
v was elected and invited the grand
master of the templars jacques de molay
to meet him to discuss a brand new
crusade this crusade never happened and
this meant that King Philippe could
criticize the order's conduct since if
they weren't trying to retake the holy
land then why did they need all of that
wealth or even to exist
Philippe decided to strike at the order
especially now that his leaders were in
France the main reason was because there
had been accusations of heresy against
the order that totally weren't
orchestrated by Philippe and wasn't at
all because Philippe owed them a Targ
antic sum of money and didn't want to
pay it back or because they had a bunch
of land and property he could seize it
was all about religion on Friday the
13th 1307 Philippe's men arrested any
Templar they could find across France
which included Malay the Pope was now
furious since the Templars answered to
him after a fair bit of torture many
Templars including two Malay confessed
to being heretics Malay retracted his
confession and so the Pope decided to
delay their trial by 1310 Philippe was
getting extremely impatient and so had
54 Templars burned at the stake
this was to preempt the Templars booting
a legal defense for themselves
implications were clear admit your guilt
and spend the rest of your life in
prison or a monastery or protest your
innocence and be bird foremost Templars
this was enough the Pope acquiesced and
Templars were arrested all across Europe
and their lands were to be ceased until
their guilt was determined in 1311 and
under
pressure from philippe clement v
summoned a council to determine what was
to be done with the templars after no
one could agree the pope threatened
anyone who disagreed with him with
excommunication in the next year the
order was suppressed the Knights Templar
were no more
the Templars property across Europe was
to be handed over to another Military
Order the Knights Hospitaller whom fully
promptly extorted for lots of money in
1314 Jacques de Molay was still in
French custody in the Pope set up a
committee to determine his guilt to
which milady declared his innocence
Philippe was frankly done with this
whole Templar business by this point and
so before the Pope could do anything he
had malade burned at the stake
the last grand master of the Templars
was gone having outlived his order by
two years a pretty grim end for an order
which been held in such high esteem
across the centuries I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette ozark a flash Henry Robin
Winston Cawood Adam Harvey and Skye
Chappell
you